okay we have to talk about yesterday's
cabinet meeting Donald Trump had a
cabinet meeting in front of the cameras
yesterday the president's cabinet is a
very important organization entity it's
part of the executive branch there are
23 members plus the vice-president 15
principal officers seven other members
Trump is the chairman of the cabinet the
cabinet is a really big deal and
yesterday's cabinet meeting was a
veritable house of horrors freak show
and I would be doing everybody a
disservice if I pretended that this
didn't go down so this is going to be a
little painful but come along with me we
are going to spend some time today going
through some of what took place
yesterday
starting with what was a completely
insane moment Donald Trump was asked
given that minority communities are
disproportionately affected by
coronavirus what specifically are you
doing for them Trump didn't answer and
at one point Trump essentially listed
races and ethnicities take a look at
this president you continue to talk
about helping minority communities what
specifically are you looking at to help
those communities what actions so one of
the things I was most proud of was the
minority community and all of the work
we've done for the minority communities
black unemployment Hispanic unemployment
Asian unemployment was the best ever in
the history of our country we've never
had anything like it
we've never had so many african-american
jobs ever ever in the history of our
country by far and we are bringing our
country back and a big focus is exactly
that with the minorities specifically if
you look at the Asians they've done
incredibly well Hispanics incredibly
well african-americans record-setting
every month you know that every month it
was a record-setting jobs number yes
black Hispanic Asian those certainly
exist that's true but it's not an answer
and by the end of this two-minute answer
which I'm not going to subject you to in
total Donald Trump was talking about
completely unrelated things like
ventilators at one point now people
often ask why don't the press call Trump
out and say you're
not answering the question you're not
answering the question the format makes
it difficult Trump will just move on to
the next person the microphone gets
moved he'll call the reporter following
up you know a nasty person or call it a
nasty question he actually does that a
little bit later today and if you
actually do get to press Trump on a
follow-up he'll just tell three more
lies and it genuinely is pretty
difficult now of course the topic of
hydroxychloroquine came up the day
before yesterday Donald Trump claimed
that he's been taking hydroxychloroquine
prophylactically for weeks and Donald
Trump claims that the best randomized
controlled trial that we have about
hydroxychloroquine is a fake false study
there was a false study done where they
gave it to very sick people extremely
sick people people that were ready to
die it was given by obviously not
friends of the administration and the
study came out the people were ready to
die
everybody was old had bad problems with
hearts diabetes and everything else you
can imagine so they gave it so
immediately when it came out they gave a
lot of false information just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right so it's true
it was given to people sick enough to
already be in the hospital that is true
but it was not a fake false study it was
a proper study it had a placebo group it
had randomization it's the best study we
have so far now let me go back to just
that last moment of trumps answer
briefly Trump does seem to forget what
the drug is called there he seems to
glitch he says hydroxy and then he has
this vacant look in his eyes he seems to
forget what he's talking about fumbles
to recover and asks the reporter if they
know what he's talking about take a look
at that moment again and just so you
understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right great studies
came out really strange stuff for short
from falling apart completely now one
more glitch here Trump said something
about
DOCSIS I I guess he was trying to say
doctor here ourselves many many doctors
doctors many doctors came out and they
said it's great now you have to go to a
doc okay so that one doesn't need too
much more discussion and then lastly on
hydroxychloroquine here is Trump saying
that hydroxychloroquine doesn't harm
anyone which is untrue there are people
who have been harmed by taking this
medication is true one way or the other
way that you like it or not it's been
around for 70 years unbelievably
effective for malaria and for lupus and
probably effective for arthritis and
what has been determined is it doesn't
harm you it's a very powerful drug I
guess but it doesn't harm you and so I
thought as a frontline defense possibly
it would be good and I've had no impact
from it I've had no I feel the same I
haven't changed I don't think too much
and at some point you know I won't take
it might be soon might be a little bit
it doesn't it doesn't seem to have any
impact on me but it seems to be a extra
line of defense and it's gotten
tremendous reviews from some people he's
not a different person as a result of
taking the drug that's good to know
now here's a really odd moment Treasury
Secretary Stephen minuchin announced
they're going to be sending out debit
cards to people with stimulus money
instead of checks or direct deposits in
some cases and he actually takes out and
presents a debit card to Trump with
Trump's name on it and he seems to be
explaining to Trump how debit cards work
which actually is not super surprising a
debit card looks like with your name on
it mr. president now there's no money
for you on it this is a blank debit card
but I want you to see what many
Americans will now get so that we could
get their money to them even quicker and
going forward we think debit cards are a
safe and secure way of delivering
refunds so I signed a letter again
Steve's had a great career now it is
quite possible that Donald Trump doesn't
no no how debit cards work he's been a
rich guy his whole life he may not
understand how a debit card works but my
question is whether this is actually a
good idea if you send someone a debit
card how do you pay rent with that how
do you pay your mortgage with that you
often can't pay those with a debit card
and when you do you sometimes pay three
four five even six percent in fees so it
seems like a strange idea to me quite
frankly we certainly need to learn more
about it and then here is Donald Trump
once again calling a female reporter
rude and telling her that's enough of
you when she tries to follow up go ahead
mr. president why haven't you announced
a plan to get 36 million unemployed
Americans back to work you're overseeing
historic economic despair I think we've
announced a plan we're opening up our
country just a rude person you are we're
opening up our country and we're opening
it up very fast the plan is that each
state is opening and it's opening up
very effectively and when you see the
numbers I think even you will be
impressed which is pretty hard to
impress you yeah go ahead and then very
last thing this is a bonus from earlier
in the day this was before Trump's
cabinet meeting Trump was asked about
Nancy Pelosi's comments about him the
day before that as a morbidly obese man
as she put it Donald Trump should not be
taking hydroxychloroquine and here's how
Trump reacted these people are sick
Pelosi is a sick woman's got a lot of
problems a lot of mental problems we're
dealing with people that have to get
their act together for the good of the
country okay so there it is a 73 year
old rich guy who literally wears orange
clown makeup says that Nancy Pelosi is
the one who is mentally sick so these
events are seen around the world the
civilized world can't believe that this
is what's happening here we are the
laughingstock and as I told you earlier
this week we are increasingly pitied by
the world because this is the guy who's
running the show people see this people
see this and even if a trumpet thinks
this is great what a great from taken
Hydra
Roxi chloroquine and calling out
reporters for nasty questions and all of
this stuff the world sees it they laugh
and they pity us and it's a really major
embarrassment it's a national nightmare
that we'd really need to end and we have
the opportunity to end it just over five
months from now I've spoken to you
before about different ways in which the
world really has been laughing at us for
a long time since Donald Trump became
president they laughed when we elected a
president who thinks climate change is a
Chinese hoax they laughed that we
elected a president who has no idea how
economics or currency or trade or
medicine or the Constitution or the law
or public transit or any of it works and
they were laughing at us early during
the corona virus pandemic and even as
recently as a couple of weeks ago many
countries were laughing at us I showed
you about ten days ago
articles from all over the world the
Netherlands South Africa Peru everywhere
ridiculing our moronic president for his
comments about bleach injections and uh
the the other things he said during that
press briefing but they're not really
laughing anymore now it has gone from
laughter to concern to actual pity the
emails I have gotten over the last few
days from our international viewers
people that used to be poking fun at
Trump's idiotic claims about vaccines
and the virus they now write to me and
say David we feel sorry for you that you
were dealing with this in the United
States we feel sorry that you are in a
situation where no matter what you do
even if you do the right things even if
you have the best intentions and the
accurate understanding of what it is
that's going on and what it is that's
necessary to deal with this virus we
feel sorry for you because your federal
government has failed they are
incompetent
there is no plan there is just a series
of Lies and disinformation and confusion
and bogus talking points and there are
even Republicans who are willing to tell
the truth they are increasingly agreeing
this is just some Republicans of course
most of them are actually behind Donald
Trump check out Republican strategist
Steve Schmidt explaining it again this
is a lifelong Republican strategist take
a take a look Donald Trump has been the
worst president this country has ever
had and I don't say that hyperbolically
he is um but he is a consequential
present and he has brought this country
in three short years to a place of
weakness that is simply unimaginable if
you were pondering where we are today
from the day where Rock Obama left
office and there were a lot of us on
that day who were deeply skeptical and
very worried about what a trump
presidency would be but this is a moment
of unparalleled national humiliation of
weakness when you listen to the
president these are the musings of an
imbecile an idiot and they don't use
those words the name-call I used them
because they're the precise words in the
English language to describe his
behavior his comportment
his actions we've never seen a level of
incompetence a level of ineptitude so
staggering on a daily basis by anybody
in the history of the country who's ever
been charged with substantial
responsibilities Steve Schmidt Schmidt
is sadly absolutely right the presidency
is deadly and as more and more countries
open up it is us people in the United
States who won't be allowed to fly into
other countries because we're a mess
here as other countries are actually
dealing with the problem as Trump talks
about a super-duper missile we'll get to
that later that's actually a phrase that
he used his son goes on TV and says it's
all going to disappear on election day
because it's merely a fake political
scandal by Democrats as that goes on
here the world is taking pity on us for
our failed leadership I was trying over
the weekend to think of an analogy to
try to apply to this because there are
people who are analyzing this
administration as if it were a normal
administration you have these people
some of them are so-called enlightened
centrists who pretend to see both sides
and find things they like and Trump and
things that they dislike you can't
evaluate this president like you can
other presidents here's an analogy I
thought of that I'm workshopping and I
want to try out on you when someone says
about Trump well you know he has an
unusual way of talking about the issues
but he's right on deregulation and he's
right on trade but maybe he's not the
best guy on coronavirus imagine okay
this is the analogy imagine I was
playing in a chess tournament and I show
up and I replace all the Queen the pawns
on the board with Queens that I take out
of my pocket before the game starts
that's insane and it's simultaneously
making a mockery of the tournament it's
also cheating I'm also either an idiot
or a bad person for doing it imagine
that a chess commentator sees me take
eight Queens out of my pocket and put
them on the board instead of the pawns
and says you know David strategy is
unusual but it's certainly an aggressive
way to play the game
well what no that doesn't make sense
yeah I mean some players use the Spanish
opening and others take queens out of
their pocket and replace the pawns we're
not talking about the same thing here so
when these enlightened centrists and
pragmatic conservatives and whoever else
when they pretend to do an analysis of
Donald Trump's presidency as if it were
even remotely normal they're failing the
sniff test on principle but there's
another issue here with very few
exceptions in the Republican Party they
are mostly just enabling this there are
a few Republicans who have taken a stand
and are saying this can't happen right
you've got people like Mitt Romney who's
the current senator from Utah Republican
you have George Conway a lifelong
Republican Steve Schmidt lifelong
Republican strategist there are a few
other Republicans I can't name them all
who have not softened their view on
Trump and they are straight up saying
this is not acceptable this is not
normal this can't be
dealt with in normal terms because
normal terms don't apply I'm not talking
about them but for the most part
Republicans in Congress in the House and
Senate have enabled this most Republican
governors have enabled this so Trump is
not alone to blame here we have to blame
the 63 million Americans that voted for
Donald Trump yes they are to blame it
doesn't matter whether you call them bad
people or stupid or it they are to blame
their actions are to blame for what we
are dealing with right now of course
Trump is to blame but the Republican
Party that mostly continues to enable
him that even before the impeachment
trial had already decided we're voting
to acquit Donald Trump on impeachment
charges they have to be held accountable
as well we have the opportunity to hold
every single one of the Republicans in
the House accountable in November we
have an opportunity to hold the
Republicans that are up for re-election
in the Senate in November which is of
the 34 up for re-election I forget the
exact number of Republicans but a number
of Republicans are up for re-election in
November they have to be held
accountable as well so last week I
mentioned that I would be significantly
limiting my coverage of the so-called
Obama gate scandal because floating
these conspiracy theories is how Donald
Trump wins it's how Trump distracts it's
how Donald Trump creates cover for
himself and in this case Donald Trump
has failed on coronavirus he's fired
four inspectors general in the last few
months and the way Trump distracts from
this is to get media debating Obama gate
get media talking about his supposedly
taking hydroxychloroquine so I'm going
to do this today because there's
actually something to tell you about
which is a leaked document that shows
that Barack Obama acted completely
appropriately back in 2016 and 2017 when
it comes to the Michael Flynn
investigation now I also you know
there's people in my audience who may
not even really know what the Obama gate
scandal supposedly is Donald Trump
clearly doesn't really understand it he
called it the greatest political crime
in the history of the United States and
yet when he was asked for an explanation
of what crime was committed Trump didn't
know where he refused to say and he went
on
to attack the journalist who asked the
question but generally and I don't want
to spend an hour on this because it's
just not worth it but we do have news
today generally Obama gate is related to
the investigation into Donald Trump's
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn and Michael
Flynn's eventual guilty pleas on on
multiple counts the allegations
generally speaking of Obama Gate our
Obama acted inappropriately
he pushed law enforcement to do this or
that too Flynn Obama was the puppeteer
of a political hack job on Flynn in
order to attack Trump even to remove
Trump and it was all illegal despite the
fact that we still don't have clarity on
what crimes supposedly were even
committed if you really want to know
more about the details you can find them
but it's just not even worth explaining
it to you we now have a released
unredacted memo from barack obama's then
National Security Advisor Susan Rice
this is what's called a contemporary
contemporaneous memo it's dated Friday
January 20 2017 it's a summary of her
notes from the January 5th meeting that
is the center of a lot of this and again
I sort of don't want to go deep on this
because it's a huge waste of time
but I want to get some of this on the
record for everybody in the letter in
the memo that Susan Rice wrote she says
there was a briefing from the
intelligence community about Russian
hacking during 2016 and after that
briefing there was a meeting which she
participated in the meeting involved
President Barack Obama then FBI director
James Comey Deputy Attorney General
Sally Yates Obama's national security
adviser Susan Rice who wrote this memo
and Vice President Joe Biden so good we
know who was there Susan Rice goes on to
say President Obama began the
conversation by stressing his continued
commitment to ensuring every aspect of
this issue is handled by the
intelligence and law enforcement
communities by the book okay the
president stressed he is not asking
about initiating or
instructing anything from a law
enforcement perspective he reiterated
that our law enforcement team needs to
proceed as it normally would by the book
it goes on to say Obama wants to ensure
that in their interactions with the
incoming Trump administration they know
if there are reasons they should not
share information fully about Russia
James Comey then confirmed they will go
by the book and added that he has some
concerns that incoming National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn is speaking more
frequently than would be normal or
typical with Russian ambassador Sergei
Kiss lyac and it could be an issue when
it comes to sensitive information Comey
said potentially the outgoing
administration the Obama administration
should be careful about passing
sensitive information related to Russia
to Michael Flynn because of the unusual
level of communication between Flynn and
the Russian ambassador it's there in
black and white Obama wanted nothing
special Comey had these concerns period
there is no crime there particularly on
the behalf of Barack Obama the only
shocking thing about this letter is how
a politically and professionally Barack
Obama handled this which I know seems
inconceivable in the era of Donald Trump
now there's a few other things to
mention Barack Obama warned Donald Trump
about Michael Flynn during the
transition period if Barack Obama were
involved in shady business why on earth
would he call attention to it by
mentioning Michael Flynn to Donald Trump
why go to Trump and say be careful with
Flynn if Obama is the one working on a
criminal trumped up bogus hack job of
Michael Flynn it makes no sense now
lastly there are people arguing that the
proof that the FBI entrapped
Michael Flynn is there are notes from
January 24th before a Michael Flynn
interrogation where they said one of the
goals of this interrogation is to get
Michael Flynn to lie and there are
people who are wildly saying that's
proof that it was a setup this is a
perjury trap this is entrapment I hate
to break it to you guys but this is
nothing controversial these are
f.b.eye notes in advance of an
interrogation about their goals for the
interrogation it's done all the time
Flynn had already lied at that point and
what they are making reference to here
is they want to get Flynn's repeated lie
on the record this is not a perjury trap
there is also you know perjury trap has
a very narrow definition and it's when
there is no reason to suspect a crime
has been committed and you bring someone
in for an interview only to get them to
lie absent any information that they've
already lied in the past or have been
potentially involved in any other crime
999 out of a thousand times when the
term perjury trapped is perjury trap is
used it simply does not apply Michael
Flynn lied multiple times he pleaded
guilty to two counts he had denied that
he told kiss lyac to back off from
escalating the situation in response to
sanctions that was a lie he lied about a
follow-up phone call I think there was a
third matter Flynn lied about that I now
can't recall and given the number of
lies that Flynn told he actually got a
pretty damn good deal he's a retired US
general he got money from at least one
foreign government Turkey he could have
been charged with conspiracy he could
have been charged with failure to
register as a foreign agent like his
business partner of Rafiki and did and
in the end he actually got a pretty good
deal lastly if James Comey had it in for
Trump and wanted Hillary to win and this
Flynn thing was part of that
why did Comey not once but twice hold an
optional press conference to talk about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails not once but twice including
right before the November election it
makes no sense it is a really dumb way
for Comey
to hurt Trump and help Hillary to hold
two press conferences or press briefings
public statements talking about the
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails so this entire Obama Gate thing
has backfired
it has spectacularly imploded and very
quickly you are starting to see the
people around Donald Trump move on to
new things and it is all to distract
from Trump's horrifying pandemic
response this is how Trump wins every
document that comes out shows that
Barack Obama certainly committed no
crimes it shows James Comey handled this
in a way that core
responded with how you would have to
sensitively deal with something when you
know you have an incoming national
security official that has to be
investigated it has evaporated before
our very eyes I have to apologize to you
today I made a mistake on a story I got
a story wrong and I want to fix it today
Donald Trump has been floating the idea
of cutting the employee side of the
payroll tax for the rest of the year as
a way to get more money in people's
pockets people earning under 138
thousand dollars per year I have
multiple times said I was supportive of
this idea because it is true that it
would in the immediate put money back in
the pockets of workers earning under a
hundred and thirty eight thousand
dollars a year but I was wrong to
support it I was wrong and I'm going to
explain why today now for people who
don't know why or what the payroll tax
is if you are a normal w-2 employee
you're not a you don't work for yourself
you're not a small business owner you
just work somewhere like most people do
you and your employer share some taxes
that come off of your payroll up until
you earn one hundred and thirty seven
thousand seven hundred dollars per year
once you get to 137 seven per year you
no longer pay these taxes there are two
taxes 12.4% towards Social Security and
2.9 percent for Medicare okay it only is
on the first hundred and thirty seven
point seven thousand dollars a year that
you earn that is a total twelve point
four and two point nine that's about
fifteen point three percent the worker
pays half and the employer pays half so
the fifteen point three percent is split
seven point six five percent for you
seven point six five percent for the
employer Trump's idea was let's suspend
the employee half seven point six five
percent through the end of the year but
you would have to pay for it when you
file your taxes in 2021 for this year so
it is not a cut it is a tax holiday now
initially I said listen I do like it
because it puts money directly back in
the hands of people earning under a
hundred and thirty eight thousand
dollars a year right now it is not a tax
cut for the rich and I thought it was a
good idea
I was wrong to support it for three
different reasons and most importantly
this is another way to actually back
handedly weaken Social Security and
Medicare and I want to go through each
of these reasons one by one so three
parts here number one the people who are
in the roughest shape right now are the
35-ish million people who lost their
jobs if you lost your job you're not
paying a payroll tax because you don't
have a job so seven point six five
percent tax holiday off the payroll tax
for people who aren't on any payroll is
not useful at all
second the people who do have jobs are
mostly earning the same amount of money
now I'm not saying they wouldn't love
not to pay this seven point six five
percent but you've got thirty five
million people that straight-up lost
their jobs so to them the payroll tax
holiday doesn't make a difference most
people fortunately for now are still
working and have not seen a decrease in
pay some people are still working but
have seen a decrease in pay but it is
not that many people the bulk of the
workers right now have not seen a
decrease in pay or are completely
unemployed and thus unaffected by a
payroll tax holiday and then number
three it is only a tax holiday this is
not a tax cut if you earn a hundred
thousand dollars for example in a year
that means in the second half of the
year you would expect to earn about
fifty thousand dollars for now saving
seven point six five percent puts thirty
eight hundred dollars back in your
pocket but it is only a tax holiday when
you file your taxes in 2021 and you
punch in how much you've paid for Social
Security and Medicare TurboTax or
whatever your accountant whoever will
spit out
hey that thirty eight hundred dollars
you didn't pay in the second half of
twenty twenty you've got to pay it back
in right now because it was only a tax
holiday so doing this payroll tax cut
would target a relatively small group it
would deprive the government of nine
hundred and fifty billion dollars in
revenue through the end of the year
it would weaken Social Security and
Medicare which could then open the door
to dirty tricks from people like Trump
and Larry Kudlow and others to say hey
we got to do something with Social
Security and Medicare we don't have that
much money because of the tax holiday
you put in place and you've still got to
pay it back next year so we can't let
them do it
I apologize that I was supportive of
this early on given everything we now
know I cannot in good conscience support
this and I'm sorry that I suggested that
it would have been a good idea we're
gonna continue following this on
Instagram our instagram is david pakman
show you can also follow me on Instagram
personally at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
Donald Trump's press secretary Kaylee
Megan Annie as some are calling her
McKenna nee Mackin Annie I don't know
how you pronounce her last name but by
that I mean you personally but you know
who I'm talking about she could barely
keep her lies straight yesterday at a 26
minute press briefing that she gave and
we have to come to the realization that
they are barely going to even try to
hide their wrongdoing at this point in
time so when she started doing these
press briefings I would livestream them
and I would sometimes say let's do an
over under and put it at three minutes
will it take Kaylee more than three
minutes to tell her first lie or less
than three minutes and she told a lie
after like 20 seconds so the next time I
streamed one of her press briefings I
said let's do the over-under at 20
seconds and then she told the first lie
within 12 seconds so there's not even a
point to doing that anymore these are
brazenly lie riddled press briefings
let's get into what happened yesterday
when we learned yesterday that Donald
Trump tweeted threats to the governor of
Michigan about if you vote by mail I may
not send you a domani that you need
including for the recent flooding in
Michigan we knew that Caylee was going
to be asked questions about this and she
was and one of the questions was a good
one which is you know you've already
admitted that Trump talks to the
Michigan Governor regularly why tweet a
threat about vote-by-mail rather than
just communicate it directly Kaley
mcenany said that that's called
transparency
yes yeah Kaylie how often does the
president talk to director vote or
acting director vote from the author to
do to the acting director of OMB often
he just was in the Oval Office with the
president so they do speak often I don't
have a readout of the president's
schedule but they do speak regularly if
he wanted to flag to him his concerns
about Michigan why don't you just tell
him instead of sending a tweet because
the President believes an unprecedented
transparency and I'm sure you as a
journalist Tom are very eager and
excited when you learn about the
president's decision-making process in
real time whether that's on Twitter for
me here up at the podiums you just said
that way that was your reasoning for him
expressing but I'm saying this is a
transparent president and I think that
that's something that you should be
allotting rather than questioning as to
why he decided to tweet this this is
truly a mix of 1984 and brave new world
and a totalitarian dictatorship where
facts simply don't matter war is peace
defeat is victory accusing a governor of
a crime on Twitter without evidence is
what they call unprecedented
transparency and good for the reporters
in the room I mean this is pretty
lukewarm praise but they kept asking
about this issue and Caylee kept doing
this move where she refers them to the
campaign you're that's really a campaign
issue you're gonna have to talk to the
2020 Trump campaign about that why is
she doing that because the question is
about something Trump said as president
about the disbursement of funds that he
manages as president why would that go
to the Trump campaign and also Caylee
mcenany herself is a lawyer nope that's
for the campaign which is basically a
way of saying go ask somebody else can
you tell us what law specifically the
president thinks the secretary
in Michigan broke by sending out the
applications and did the Secretary of
State in Georgia also break that law by
sending out applications for their
buyers I mean I referenced you to the
campaign these are ballot questions I
reference you to the campaign on this
the president and their employer my
sermon employers the White House so
that's not a campaign question that's
the president saying that is that you
have an absentee ballot so I would refer
you to the campaign on that front and I
would note to you that many of those
ballots that are submitted via mail can
be fraudulent I cited to the bipartisan
study I can read it again maybe you
weren't paying attention when I read it
the first time so read it again
President Carter a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots remained the largest
source of potential voter fraud so if
you cast a ballot via mail and you do so
fraudulently that would be an illegal
act and I'd point you to that and for
further I'd point you to my former
employer which is the Trump campaign
also important I want to remind you and
I'm gonna become a bit of a broken
record on this vote by mail fraud is
mathematically non-existent yesterday I
gave you the numbers 250 million people
have voted by mail in the last 20 years
there are seven to eight cases not seven
hundred to eight percent there are seven
to eight cases of vote by mail fraud per
year there is way more in person voter
fraud of course there are more in person
ballots cast but those numbers also are
completely insignificant this type of
what I call retail strategy voter fraud
is essentially non-existent do not fall
for it now here's a really Orwellian
moment where Kaylie mcenany was asked
about Susan Rice Susan Rice is Barack
Obama's former national security adviser
she recently a letter that she wrote a
memo that she wrote in 2017 which is
exculpatory of Barack Obama in the
context of Obama gate was recently
released I told you about it yesterday
Kaley mcenany does this thing where she
has a page in this notebook with
disinformation that she will turn to
whenever a question is asked that even
tangentially relates to something she
has in her book now that's fine that's
not I'm not criticizing her for having
notes
it's called being prepared it
called research that's okay but the
thing is if Cayley hears one word that
relates to her pages she will turn to
the page and read the page even if it
has nothing to do with the question and
in this case the name Susan Rice was
mentioned in a very specific exculpatory
context and Kaleigh turns to her Susan
Rice page and she reads two minutes of
unrelated attacks on Susan Rice sort of
sounds like she's arguing that Susan
Rice's letter was just a lie and I'm
actually going to play the full two
minutes for you normally I would I would
just slice out the key part but what you
really need to see Susan Rice's name is
mentioned Kaylee turns to a page about
Susan Rice spends two minutes reading
unrelated things about Susan Rice and
then quickly ends the press conference
and leaves this is happening at almost
every single one of these press
conferences let's take a look
I apologize for subjecting you to two
minutes of this but it's important and I
know you brought up Susan Rice in that
context but I'm going to bring her up in
another context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified from Susan Rice on
Inauguration Day which is so peculiar
set the scene it's an odd Eurasian day
you're moving out of the White House
this is the most powerful building on
planet earth Susan Rice is moving out to
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing her boxes
she's not being nostalgic about her time
in the White House what she's doing is
writing an email worth three times she
writes that President Obama emphasized
to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn by the book by the book by
the book she writes that three times as
a Shakespeare said thou doth protest too
much Susan Rice he didn't have the Susan
Rice part in there but I'll add that in
to she was asked specifically about the
unmasking and Michael Flynn after her
after she discussed it on January 5th in
the Oval Office with Obama after she
wrote this email to herself on
inauguration day she was asked by a good
journalist Judy Woodruff
about this email and she said about the
unmasking of Michael Flynn not the email
but the unmasking she was asked
specifically about núñez exclaims
specifically so let me clarify was known
as his claim and she said I know nothing
about this so it was a
and then Susan Rice since no one brought
it up to me I will bring it up to you
her attorney said that this was the
first opportunity three weeks after this
oval office meeting that she had to
write this email memorializing her Oval
Office meeting with a Barack Obama
discussing Michael Flynn it was her
first opportunity she said interesting
because she had an opportunity in those
three weeks On January 10th to do a
passing of the baton event with none
other than Michael Flynn where she
praised him wished him success and
talked about the great transition into
the White House and then on January 12th
she was able to participate in a story
that published on that date in the
lifestyle section of the Washington Post
so she never had time to write this
email until inauguration day as she's
rushing out the door when in fact she
had an opportunity to do all of those
things I'll leave that with you thank
you for bringing up Susan Rice not in
the context that I wished but for
allowing me to share that with you so
the reason I played all of that is that
it's really important for you to
understand that this is what they claim
is radical transparency and it's not of
course it's reading pre-planned talking
points and then walking off the stage
before anybody can say hey that stuff
you just said has nothing to do with my
question and the saddest part the most
tragic part of this is that Trump is
lover they think she's doing so well at
her job she doesn't answer questions she
does 20-minute press briefings
yesterday's was 26 minutes after showing
up 30 40 minutes late that it's her
speech and her questions 26 minutes
she reads non sequitur material from her
notes and then she leaves and the
trumpets are gleeful because to them
this counts a strength turning weird at
that like yesterday she turned a
question back on a reporter don't you
agree XYZ but that's not what a reporter
is there for lying barely keeping it
together attacking the media walking out
abruptly that's the state of affairs and
the trumpets are thrilled because they
believe she's owning the liberal media
we live in a very very backwards country
right now let me remind you monday is
Memorial Day we will be doing a one-day
huge membership special if you've been
thinking
about getting a membership membership of
course the number one way to support our
show Monday is a perfect day to do it
Trump's phone call wasn't perfect Monday
is the perfect day to get yourself a
membership if you want to be notified
about the Monday special just get on my
mailing list at david pakman.com i can't
tell you right now what things are going
to be like in November I can only tell
you what things are like right now and
right now Donald Trump and Joe Biden are
seeing a shift in who is supporting them
and older voters are abandoning Donald
Trump and they are flocking to Joe Biden
in large numbers why do we care well we
care about every vote but in particular
we care because older voters are a key
voting group for Donald Trump if you
look back at the 2016 exit polls Trump
won voters age 50 or older by the
largest margin Trump one vote voters in
their 40s by a little bit and Trump lost
all age groups from 39 and under
Republicans in general have done better
with older voters than younger voters
for a very long time so the the
important thing is Trump needs older
voters to win in November
back in 2016 Trump won voters aged 45 to
64 by 4% right now we've seen a
five-point swing with Biden leading that
group 45 to 64 by about one and a half
points that's a five and a half point
reversal from 2016 normal caveats it's
early a lot can change when we look at
voters 65 plus Trump won that group by
13 points in 2016 he is now losing 65
plus by 1.2 Biden that is a 14-point
swing now why is this happening
speculation it's speculation right now
someone wrote to me and said David older
folks are dying from coronavirus and
it's the Trump older folks that are more
likely to die because they're not
wearing masks or staying home I
understand the logic of that it's been
floated we don't have any evidence for
that right now
coronavirus in Jeb
is the most sort of obvious explanation
older folks are most at risk from
coronavirus and they might react the
most strongly to Donald Trump's
mishandling of it this problem with
older voters that Trump is having could
explain why Trump is not doing well in
states with older populations Florida is
one such state that's a key state
Florida's population is the fifth oldest
in the country the latest polls have
Trump losing to Biden by six in Florida
more importantly for today's story
Quinnipiac has Trump losing by ten in
Florida among voters 65 and older so I
don't want to get anybody's hopes up
we've got to count every vote this is a
snapshot right now but if Trump loses
older voters in Florida by anything
close to ten even by six or seven it's
over for Trump
now if coronavirus starts to wane if the
economy recovers or appears to recover
and Trump can attach his name to the
recovery things could turn around very
quickly so you know when you start
slicing and dicing the electorate in
this way it's really difficult to glean
anything super useful from it what I do
think is interesting is the following we
believe that about 13% of people who
voted for Obama Biden in 26 2012 voted
for Trump in 2016
13% of Obama's 12 voters went for Trump
in 16 if Biden can get back just half of
those people and not lose anybody that
voted for Hillary that translates to a 7
million vote victory in the popular vote
for Biden in 2020
now you could win the popular vote by 7
million and lose the electoral college
it's theoretically possible it we've
never seen it we've never seen it so now
go back and think people who were on
board with Obama in 2012 and voted Trump
for some reason in 2016 are they likely
to stick with Trump over a guy they
already voted for years prior and Joe
and Joe Biden if he only gets half of
them back it looks very good for Biden
again nothing is guaranteed if Biden can
win back just half
of those voters who went from Obama in
12 to Trump in 16 he has a very very
good starting point for 2020 so what
does this mean for us nothing
all it means is every single one of us
needs to vote remember that on Monday
Memorial Day will have a huge David
Pakman show membership special get
notified on Monday Memorial Day by
signing up for our newsletter at david
pakman.com it's quick it's easy it's
free and then Monday you will hear about
this incredible membership discount no
time for the voice mail I'll talk to you
on the bonus show today